and he can you tell us the first day you
actually plunked down that credit card
and what research did you do before you
obtained those cards or did you already
have them in your possession yeah I mean
I had I had the majorities in my
possession I had been applied on this
for like when I decided to make the film
I then I'd then turn around and applied
for him right away
early some of them but I had been
planning on making the film and doing
research for about you know five years
building my credit up saving money and
waiting for the right time and then once
we decided to do it that's sort of how
those diseases that was there was just a
decision it was just I said to myself
you need to make this film I never lose
your percent interest for ya ever it's
pretty nice yeah definitely like I said
before for for people that are thinking
about doing that do your homework and
save as much as you can try to get your
credit score through the roof and you'll
definitely get some perks but anyway you
look at it it's idiotic that's a
terrible idea
but maybe you get lucky or maybe you
work hard enough and and things turn out
alright in our and in our case I mean we
we don't know yet but we do really like
what the how that we do really do relate
the project and how it turned out so
other than that I'll figure out the rest
I need to work for the next five years
digging ditches them I'll do that well
you said you saved every penny that you
earn what are some tips that you can
share that you what I mean I didn't say
that I say I saved a lot of over the
years of some money and then ultimately
that allowed with money and good credit
for additional credit
I would just say again it's it's staying
focused on what you want to do and I
don't know if there's really a formula
it's just if you're gonna just if you
decide to make the film and put in the
work or it completely depends on what
your goal is our goal was to see the
film through every stage and to be
honest it to as many people as possible
with our resources that's getting ready
to happen and we don't know what that
means or how that's going to turn out
but we're excited that it's at least at
this point what was the first thing that
you charged probably are monitored pair
production monitor for the shoulder
mount it was kind of the first thing for
production anyway made burgers actually
you know might have been it might have
been Todd's bathroom oh yes I remember
going through him in the store and
deciding which one we were going to use
you know yeah I'm the bathroom man yes
you